people wonder if I work for YouTube
are they going to report my income to
the IRS yes through a 1099 all at 1099
is is a tracking mechanism basically
saying hey I paid John Smith 100K which
means we're going to write it off so
what he does with it is his own business
but that is definitely a tracking
mechanism and them telling the IRS and
some people wonder too they go well if I
make less than 700 or less than six
hundred dollars like I don't have to pay
taxes is that true very untrue you could
have 200 of income because you sold
something on Facebook Marketplace and
that could be taxable
welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean Cannell here and I'm fired up
because this is episode three of a
three-part series I did with Matt
Bontrager on YouTube taxes explained
money saving tips for Content creators
Advanced Tax saving strategies and
loopholes for YouTube creators and it's
been a power packed series now I want to
encourage you
um you could definitely listen through
this whole episode but go to the
archives check out episode one that was
kind of some beginners tips and some
foundational tips although there were
some juicy nuggets in there that you
don't want to miss episode 2 Matt
specifically broke down five of the best
Tax Strategies and tax loopholes so you
can ethically pay less taxes as a
content creator which what does that
mean It ultimately means more money in
your pocket for you and your family or
more money in your business to be
investing and scaling your business more
cameras more gear More Travel More
Vehicles real estate office space a lot
of different opportunities and so check
out those episodes but now in episode
three
we're going to be diving into some of
your questions and I asked you to submit
questions I I sent out a tweet I put out
a couple Community tab posts and I
gathered some questions and we answered
those here which as just a side reminder
I would love to stay connected with you
on social media from time to time we
want to get feedback from you and so you
could definitely follow me on at Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel at
Sean Cannell on all the social media
platforms where official think media on
Instagram if you're subscribed on
YouTube we do surveys and polls from
time to time on the community Tab and we
want to do this in the future if you've
got questions let us know future
episodes you want to see from US future
topics you'd want to cover and we're
also going to have Matt back on the show
so drop something in the comments
related to that now why should you trust
Matt Bontrager well he is a certified
public accountant licensed in Nevada and
the managing partner co-founder of true
books an accounting firm specializing in
real estate he strives to help clients
navigate complex tax code for their
benefit as well as keeping their
accounting records organized and up to
date he's also a content creator himself
an in-demand speaker for events
masterminds and small groups of Business
Leaders and teams and he is a specialist
relating to the Creator economy Matt has
a lot of clients that are at all kinds
of different levels that are our content
creators so you're really getting
someone that's knowledgeable and
something that a lot of CPAs are not now
today's episode is brought to you by
thinkcpas.com that is simply a website
that'll take you to a form to
potentially check out Matt's services
and see if they would be a good fit
working with them we are true books
clients Matt is our CPA and him and his
team have been absolutely amazing if you
want to learn more about that there's a
link in the show notes but with that
let's dive into the juicy content today
[Music]
so we are back with episode three with
Matt Bontrager from True books in
episode one we talked about the
foundations of setting your business
upright saving money on taxes
um whatever YouTube creators should know
to be able to pay less taxes and a lot
of missed deductions in episode two we
talked all about
um how to do some Advanced strategies we
had five of those we went pretty deep
now we're gonna kind of just go into
some q a and I recommend listening until
the end because there could be little
nuggets that could save you five hundred
dollars little nuggets that could save
you uh not only a couple thousand
dollars but that could amount to tens of
thousands over the next couple years and
it's really going to position you
um for your future as a business owner
as a content creator and so these are
really some money saving tips that every
Creator should know and um and just some
general topics that came in from our
community tab Twitter and other places
so here's the first question Matt Jen
actually asked this what's your take on
the recent legislation regarding the IRS
um hiring new people and should we
ultimately be more cautious about taking
write-offs
um because of a fear of audits no to
being more cautious but for those of you
listening who don't have your books in
order AKA you couldn't get a profit and
loss schedule I would be on high alert
now because if you are flagged for audit
the first thing they ask for is oh you
spent 20 grand in office supplies show
me a ledger with all of those
transactions
I'm gonna bet 99 of the time you don't
have that your accounting software will
something like QuickBooks so I wouldn't
be weary about taking deductions but I
would be very weary and concerned if you
don't do your bookkeeping okay and so
and also just back up on the story so
what was the announcement the IRS that
they're going to hire like 87
000 which they to put that in
perspective because a number's a number
they only have like 77 000 that work for
them now so you're gonna more than
double the entire staff of the IRS and
and probably be coming after small
business owners one thousand they say
they're not coming after well I've seen
it that they're not coming after people
or small businesses that make less than
four hundred thousand complete lie it it
wouldn't work that way and that's so
interesting that the question was wow
should we shrink back should we be
afraid should you know which I wonder if
that's even the message they want to
send potentially which because it's
interesting that that was the question
it's interesting that's a question
because my what I'm hearing you say and
this is my I actually want to double
down even more I want to Triple down on
my education but you're also saying and
take as many ethical you know write-offs
and deductions possible but you're
saying you got to have good books be
wary if you're going to be messy yeah if
you're going to be clean and organized
you're doubling down on the
opportunities is what I want to call
them I like deductions I love it now
here's a here's a question
um if you use a credit card and you then
also get cash back for points are those
taxed deductible
the cash are the tax is the cash that
you earn yes the Cash Back Rewards that
you earn could become taxable taxable
income yes what about travel points
likely no but again the fair market
value of what you received which is
therefore the flight cost could be
taxable likely not got it okay so how
would you recommend Bookkeeping on that
flight costs keeping the right sort of
your itineraries for the value of those
flights and then credit card reward
points if you're getting that as cash
back that's going to hit the bank that's
going to hit your credit card as a
credit so in your accounting software
you would hit it as income all right so
Marcos Ortiz asked
um taxes for Content creators uh people
wonder if I work for YouTube
um are they going to report my income to
the IRS
yes through a 1099 all a 1099 is is a
tracking mechanism basically saying hey
I paid John Smith 100K which means we're
going to write it off so what he does
with it is his own business but that is
definitely a tracking mechanism and them
telling the IRS and some people wonder
too they go well if I make less than 700
or less than 600 like I don't have to
pay taxes is that true very untrue you
could have two hundred dollars of income
because you sold something on Facebook
Marketplace and that could be taxable
but so I wouldn't rely on whether you
got the 1099 or not so many people don't
cut them got it so the key with the 1099
is they start being issued at a certain
amount exactly which is like what 700
600 bucks 600 bucks and I love the venmo
memes out there with this sure so the
mistake that people make is they just
think oh well I'm trying to stay under
the radar here technically you're uh
required to report all income exactly
okay so his second question
um was and and did actually Double Down
that so now it's your responsibility
YouTube's going to pay you they've offed
it from their books oh yeah but you're
responsible to report your AdSense
earnings which comes as a 1099 and
whether it does or it doesn't just it's
your responsibility to go in the back
end of Google and be like oh shoot I
didn't change my address oh I didn't
update my email I didn't update you got
to make sure that you're going and
thinking about where are you collecting
money like if someone's sending you
money you know you could think about the
records and that would be coming from
YouTube that also be coming from someone
like Amazon we recommend uh affiliate
marketing a lot and I eventually built a
six-figure income of Amazon paying me
that's also 10.99 income yep and so I'm
stacking these up it gets a little
complex for uh content creators
potentially because you might have
Amazon sending you money YouTube sending
you money uh patreon sends you money
that's income yep patreon takes five
percent but whatever they're paid and
some people also make the mistake is
they think about well do I I pay money
off of do I have to understand YouTube's
cut do I have like when is it paid is it
over simplify simplifying it to just say
how much money did you get sent yeah I
was just gonna say don't worry about
that collect the money and keep doing
what you're doing but yes and that's
where accounting comes in track the
money hitting your bank account got you
yeah um a second question Marcos asked
is is there a preferred credit card for
a business of this uh kind that you'd
recommend for Content creators I'm a fan
of Amazon I mean I myself have a lot of
camera equipment now after watching the
think Channel shout out to you guys
thank you so much but
um I'm a fan of Amazon which I'm pretty
sure is five percent cash back towards
Amazon but it's really whatever you want
so if you're a travel person if you're a
cash back person if you're a perk Point
person whatever you want that's smart
and I know there's even some people who
devote reverse engineering the trip you
want to take yeah to the certain travel
credit card we actually just do like a
cash back credit card uh and then we
reinvest that cash
um and uh and so there's also there are
like Creator startup companies like
carrots
which also just speaks their their
business model is I don't know how good
the incentives are but they um your
credit limit is not necessarily is
correlated by your subscriber count and
things like that because they just are
having empathy for the crater economy to
understand that there's different
metrics as to maybe what your business
is capable of so they're trusting you
with a limit that may be a traditional
business is like what do you do yeah you
make YouTube videos we're gonna give you
a two thousand dollar limit carrot sees
what you're doing they're like we'll
give you a 200 000 limit yeah so um
that's a great question Rick asks what
are the pros and cons of running
multiple businesses under one entity
using dbas for different businesses DBA
stands for doing business as so maybe
you only have one LLC but you have a
bunch of different dbas is there uh
upsides and downsides to that such a
good question so tax wise it's really
not going to change anything at all what
I want you to focus on there is is is
risk for example we have somebody that
flips homes they now are going to Branch
out and do education
once education gets big enough I'm going
to set up a separate LLC why there's way
more risk that occurs with flipping
homes slip and Falls contractors putting
nails through their foot whatever so to
separate the liability which is again
what LLCs are made for that is when I
would separate that out so but if you
have one LLC collecting AdSense
affiliate income you're on stage once a
month speaking you do side photography
uh those four streams you can have that
flow to one LLC one business bank
account and you're fine and is the cons
of doing that that as it gets more
complex is it going to be are you trying
to run multiple P L's under the
difference I was just gonna say so you
don't need to but in that example of
somebody flipping and doing education as
an operator I want to see how my
education business is doing aside from
my flipping business so one of the cons
to splitting it up would be separate
sets of books so now your bookkeeper has
to keep a separate set and so yeah if
you have a bookkeeper it may just be
doubling down and paying them more
because now they're working maybe not
double the hours but 30 40 more whatever
to manage everything but hopefully too
to your point this you're getting more
sophisticated more money's coming in
you're bolting on an additional business
maybe the businesses like for us we
realize the same thing with events we
want to separate out events because
events take more risk exactly but we've
made it this far with actually our event
um it's it's all been under one and as
we look forward we're like well we got
to be smarter and we're uh embracing
that complexity Corin uh creates asks
how do you know when you should start
paying taxes quarterly if you suddenly
start making money mid-year do you
switch the method of paying taxes so to
frame it you're you're a YouTube Creator
you finally get monetized but it's the
middle of the year
um do you start thinking about setting
money aside are you paying quarterly
taxes immediately you're still a sole
proprietor you haven't made an entity
yet what are your thoughts so if you
want to hold on to the money and not
make a payment you're going to pay half
a percent in a penalty to the IRS likely
going to be very minimal so if you want
to not pay it don't pay it we have
clients to do that if you want to pay
that then you can pay that it ideally is
going to be paid September 15th that's
the third quarter payment for estimated
payments you would cut that to the IRS
or third option just set that money
aside when people ask me how much money
they should set aside because they're
self-employed I honestly tell them 10 to
30 because it's going to be a rough
range right they may have more
deductions than others and stuff like
that though so I would say that's a
personal choice
got it and so to be clear though when
are you obligated to pay taxes quarterly
when you're self-employed and have
self-employed income so basically if I'm
a W-2 my employer is withholding this
for me and you're remitting it to the
IRS if I make money because I flip
things on the side I make money from
AdSense whatever the case is I then now
have to start remitting I need to think
about quarterly so you could be a sole
proprietor you might be an LLC might be
an S corp it doesn't matter if you're
self-employed you should be sending in
quarterly tax payments correct and like
you said you can just pay that penalty
and not do it a lot of people are behind
they they bury their head in the sand
but not only could it save you money it
helps you with more foresight oh yeah it
helps you be thinking about being on top
of your money managing your money
intelligently
um brilliant on the same page together
asked any tips for finding an accountant
who understands the Creator economy in
your area or online honestly a Google
search or if you come across somebody
online line that is obviously portraying
themselves as somebody as an expert in
that field ask them when you have a call
with them or their team this is my
situation that's what the two minutes or
the DM is worth like hey this is my
business are you versed in it they're
going to tell you yes or no and then by
then you got to do a little bit of your
own due diligence like maybe ask
somebody that you know works with them
or do a little bit more Rabbit Hole
searching online but totally try and ask
them questions as to what you're doing
and say hey could you help me that's a
great Point having some good questions
ready related to your business and a
couple of thoughts is listen to these
three episodes to think about the
questions so this whole series probably
has you thinking entirely different and
if if the CPA accountant you're talking
to is completely mystified and has no
clue then they're probably not the right
person and then again secondly uh if you
want to connect with Matt and his team
oh they're there to serve and answer
your questions regardless regardless see
if it's a good fit that's think cpas.com
um and you can also follow Madison
social media and there's others on
social media as well I I like the same
uh the uh are one of the prior guys we
work with had a big YouTube channel I
obviously like that because he was doing
the thing he was into it
um and so uh that's a great tip makers
unify says should you go through the
process of applying for an LLC on your
own or use something like LegalZoom
if you're because the process is very
easy to set up an LLC for example here
in Nevada where we are I can do that
like in three minutes so I would say if
you're confident in doing it yourself do
it yourself it's really simple if not I
would pay like a Legal Zoom or an online
service because if you go to an
attorney's office like your local
attorney your local CPA there's a chance
they're going to send you a two thousand
dollar bill and I think I'm much more of
a proponent of use that cash flow in
your business to do marketing buy
equipment something like that so I would
use an online service if you're not
comfortable doing it yourself they go on
and they ask what can you actually write
off on your taxes and I'll point you to
um the first episode we went deep into
some of those things kind of like the
five biggest ones that creators Miss but
then they get to a specific question and
they say for instance I have a DIY
channel a do-it-yourself channel so I
purchase many items to use in my DIYs
that I can show on YouTube can I write
all of this off yes
so if you are carpentry or crafting
you're going to write your glue off
you're going to write your foam off your
foam board your Staples your Staples all
the different stuff kind of office
supplies type of things all etc etc
amazing and uh for more on that I highly
recommend check out episode one we'll
link up the full series in the show
notes uh but we get more into that in
episode one okay so don bird asks what's
the best way to prepare taxes when all
of your income is a is as a 1099
independent contractor
first have a profit and loss statement
your income your expenses
two would be it's going to be on your
personal tax return on what we call a
Schedule C a Schedule C is a form that
says hey I'm self-employed here's my
income here's my expenses that's it so
it's really going to mirror what your p
l is just on your tax return he then
asks how do you document and deduct
paying for your own contractors editors
Developers
money is going to leave the bank account
through their venmo Zell a check that
you pay them an ATM withdrawal and what
are you going to do on QuickBooks if you
use QuickBooks it's going to show oh 400
left the bank account what was that for
drop down contractors done now this goes
a little bit more broad but I'm glad
he's bringing the question up how do you
handle profit sharing when collaborating
with other creators
we do a project and we make 5 000 bucks
and the deal is we're gonna go 50 50.
the end of the day five thousand dollars
me and you hits my bank account yeah I
then sell you 2500 assuming my daily
limit is that high I sell you 2500 when
that shows up on my accounting system I
just hit shared service I hit contractor
whatever I want to call it and therefore
it's an expense and it would show on my
p l 5000 of income 2500 because we
always get the question well am I gonna
since the five thousand dollars hit my
bank account am I going to be stuck with
all that as an ex right or as income no
because I just spent 2500 to you so the
nuances of how you're structuring the
deal that's entirely up to you punchline
is it doesn't matter if all the money
comes to you so long as it leaves money
and money out yeah so as long as it
leaves your business it leaves your 1099
Schedule C now it's on them exactly and
so then their responsible tax wise and
um and that's actually one of the cool
things ultimately I mean you think about
ways of getting a write-off paying
people more finding ways to hire people
and help them win with you that's your
goal as you build a team it's helping
people around you in obviously that
money leaves you now they're responsible
for the taxes but it's uh it would get
that off of your books all right that
able disabled guy he says uh would you
please ask how YouTubers can set up a
non-profit or a not-for-profit instead
of an LLC what are the tax pros and cons
for like a non-profit so the not so the
first thing would be most of the people
entering this business are in it for
profit or at least to use the proceeds
for something that they need nonprofits
are very strict on what you can use the
money for and it has to follow a mission
statement that you get approved by the
IRS so you'd have to go through somebody
who would set that up for you and again
have a mission statement that you feel
would be approved by the IRS so is it
possible we have a lot of Ministries and
people like Christian YouTubers that
watch our Channel if if they're mainly
going to be making videos and even
having like brand sponsorships from like
Christian Mingle dating app
um but it's a Ministry like and maybe
maybe they have a local church or
they're also a traveling Minister
um is that situation and I guess I'm
assuming like there that has been
approved by the IRS
is there then supposed and cons for that
or is there too much YouTube income for
that not to work as a as a non-profit it
wouldn't be a question of too much
income it would be so yes I think you
could set that up right I think we've
seen precedent of that but it would be
are you comfortable with the how you
have to spend the money once you set
that up because if the goal is to set
that up but then really use the cash for
personal use and to do other business
deals with you may not have that
flexibility because the cash has to stay
within that Foundation or organization
so the limitation of the non-profit is
maybe there's some quote-unquote tax
advantages if your mission is just to
grow the mission as big as possible
exactly hire other people expand more
and and do more of that and you set a
reasonable salary yep but basically your
reasonable salary is kind of the cap of
what you're taking out and everything is
staying in the non-profit for the
furthering of the mission exactly if you
want to be a Christian YouTuber but have
a lot more freedom and flexibility you
should just be for-profit for-profit got
it
um but then just buy real estate and
we'll get you to pay no tax yep thank
you there you go unless yeah listen to
episode two for more tips on that yeah
HPM Wellness says do you need to have
insurance if you're selling courses that
are related to Fitness or nutrition
tax that's not required as a friend
advisor I would say probably not a bad
idea because I guess Fitness they could
get hurt nutrition they could get hurt
you recommend something someone does it
something bad happens they sue you your
insurance covers it ideally all right
now one other question for you Matt and
that is
um any kind of resources you'd recommend
for people that are on this journey they
want to get their life in order their
finances in order and they also want to
continue their financial education is
there any books software things you
recommend yeah book Rich Dad Poor Dad by
Robert Kiyosaki the reason I love that
is I feel like it's going to give you
the mindset that you need to get into
being a business owner and why it's so
preferential it's not this bad thing
it's great so that book is really going
to help hone that in two software if you
leave with one thing today it is the
importance of doing your bookkeeping so
that you can meet with an advisor to
help you and I would use QuickBooks I'm
not affiliated with them I just simply
love it that's what we put our clients
on that's what I use purse personally
it's the easiest software out there and
then to get a little bit more nerded out
on a software if you use a vehicle for
your business and you want that big
deduction something like a mile IQ to
check your mileage and write it off yep
Rich Dad Poor Dad and QuickBooks though
those alone will really bootstrap you
amazing and if people want to connect
with you you're always sharing great
information and resources especially on
your Instagram what's the handle at
mattbontrager amazing and then a couple
other resources is if you want to
connect with Matt and his team that's
who we use here at think media as our
certified public accountant they're
based here in Nevada Ryan Pineda and
Matt co-founded true books and we love
them because as you continue to have
more well first of all they're content
creators so they're in the crater
economy but they're also incredibly
smart and specializing in real estate
and so if you want to just uh connect
with them see if they're a good fit for
you and your business as well as know
that we we referred you so you can get a
great deal if you go to think CPAs so
thinkcpas.com of course those will all
be in the show notes and then I also
want to recommend if you haven't checked
out our recordings from our event video
successecrets.com the event was actually
called growth video live but we've
turned it into an online course 3 days
of content the third day was devoted to
Advanced business strategy we had like
Bradley speaking Ryan Pineda you did
sessions there's a panel during the
first two days there's a great uh
special sale happening there as well and
so if you want to invest in your
education more that is a write-off
towards uh your education it's going to
help you get percent yeah it's got we
get more views help you get make more
money but also get your financial
intelligence uh higher as well I
definitely recommend that that's video
successecrets.com it's an online course
of a three-day video marketing social
media YouTube and business event Matt
was one of the speakers check that out
as well Matt I am super grateful for you
pouring into US during this three-part
series Marathon mode I'm excited to have
you back in the future I appreciate any
time
[Music]
so I hope you've been getting massive
value out of this three-part series with
Matt and I want to encourage you all
three episodes are live now whether on
the audio platform you love to listen to
the think media podcast on or on the
YouTube channel and so block some time
and I encourage you to listen through
all of those now these are the kind of
episodes where it's probably good to
listen with a pen and a piece of paper
as well as writing down next steps so I
do want to encourage you as Mattis told
us it's probably times time to start
getting our receipts and our books in
order it's probably time to sign up for
QuickBooks QuickBooks Online it's
probably time to potentially decide
who's going to be filing your taxes and
do you need to pick out a new accountant
or a new CPA do you need to download
mile IQ so you could be tracking any
kind of business related mileage and all
of the above and so block some time
because even though this isn't
necessarily the funnest topic to talk
about you know let's just go viral we'll
figure this stuff out later I definitely
unders understand that mentality but
what I've learned especially if you want
to play at higher levels of the game you
got to get started now with your
education for me I read a book called
Rich Dad Poor Dad which of course will
link that up in the show notes I read it
back in like 2007-2008 and here's the
truth we did not have a lot of money
coming in I was barely making any money
working like quarter time at church I'm
waiting tables at Red Robin and
eventually I started our business
clearvision media and we had money
coming in but a lot of money going out
in fact cameras lenses video editing
computer home office all kinds of
different expenses now the cool thing
was I was thinking then about write-offs
and thinking about deductions in those
early days of business but ultimately
this if you don't know my story this is
when we got crushed 2009 was when my
wife Sony almost died
um she was all we were dual income and
so her income dried up as it should have
as she was no longer able to work at
that time and we started having medical
bills piling up the church fell apart I
lost that job and it didn't even really
pay very well
um and then I was hustling trying to
work in my business and we also got
crushed in real estate and so I was in a
season where there wasn't a lot of money
to manage it was me we were mainly just
watching the money disappear
but I never stopped investing in my
financial education I just at that time
committed I'm gonna just keep learning
about this even though these terms seem
complex and I thought I understood it
and then I tried again and oh I had it
wrong and I'm just going to keep trying
to get around people that are smarter
than me I'm going to start just keep
trying to get around people who
understand this stuff talk about this
stuff and now fast forward you know
since 2009 to you know 2022 and 2023 and
it's crazy I first of all think about
well we didn't quit and think media has
grown and now think media is 22 people
and it's been amazing to see the
Miracles that have happened in my wife's
Health through prayer and through
doctors and through now having two kids
and just all these incredible things
that have happened as well as persisting
in our business but also having to grow
as Leaders having to grow as business
owners my wife's a CFO I'm the CEO what
the heck we even know we are small town
kids college dropouts we don't really
think about the tax code but we
committed to learning we committed to
growing and now think media is a
multi-multi-million Dollar business we
got HR we got insurance we got we got
all this different stuff happening and I
would say that like one of the things I
love that Matt said was you gotta like
be it before you are it that is not what
he said but he said it was something
like that you gotta it's like you you
gotta start like walking in the steps
learning about the steps far before
you're ready it's it's like you got to
be thinking big in small places I think
you should be acting big in small places
I don't I think you should never let
your small town make you small-minded
and even though I started think media
from a house that eventually we had to
short sell that we were house hacking
with another family and their daughter
and two other roommates and then they
all moved out and we couldn't afford the
payment and I was mission command think
media Central back in 2010 was me just
having a big dream and like not having
the knowledge not having all the answers
me just wanting to punch fear in the
face and press record and us just
getting started and then we never quit
in investing in our learning and
leveling up we had to learn how to set
up employees in other states and all
this kind of stuff that could be very
overwhelming but the big message today
is just commit to your financial
education why don't they teach this
stuff in schools I don't know why did I
go to school for you know from K through
12th grade and I didn't learn 99 of the
most practical and important skill sets
for the real world I'm really not sure
but what I am excited about is no matter
what has happened in your life up until
this point it's always a new day to get
the skills to get the educate education
to get equipped for the real world and
we're here to help you so I definitely
encourage you listen to these three
episodes connect with Matt if you want
to connect with them and of course all
the different resources we mentioned
will link up in the show notes uh
whether you listen to this on audio or
on the YouTube channel and so spend some
time checking those out as well my name
is Sean Cannell and I'm super grateful
that you are a part of the think media
podcast community and I want to
encourage you to buckle your seatbelt
and make sure you're subscribed because
we have really valuable episodes coming
your way soon so stay locked in with us
because we are on a mission to help 10
000 purpose-driven content creators make
a difference in the world while building
an income that supports them and their
families with YouTube and so stick
around I hope you're one of the 10 000
and we're here for you every week on the
think media podcast
foreign